I don't get how people think that the
reclining the seat thing is just
survival and you know what I don't want
to hear any of it anymore I don't want
to hear anybody being like well let's
consider it to no dude it is not it is
considerate it's actually considered to
not fly how about that drive when I
recline all the way back and it goes
into somebody's lap if I I hope it goes
back far enough to where I could open my
eyes and see them upside down and then I
want to say you're welcome Hey dude
you're a [__] man the sea reclines let
it recline
Johnny Cochran
if the silver clouds let him recline
but dude let it recline man this [__]
reclines and the guy's like oh yeah yeah
I know people I can't believe there's
people out there that actually are like
no it's disrespectful to recline your
seat bro I paid for it also the seat
reclines I'm not re-jiggering the seat
to make it recline it reclines therefore
if my seat goes to your [__] tank
swear it's gone
take it up with [__] Delta man this
[__] isn't my problem I'm being
respectful because this is what I want
to do and we're all in this together one
time I was on the plane and this guy I I
like was trying to turn my TV on and I
was hitting the button on the TV in
front of it you know the headrest in
front of it and the guy turns around he
says this is my seat that's yours
and I was like
bro
it's crazy how people just go zero to
sixty
when they're in public like already
pissed off about their situation
everything about flying is uncomfortable
everything
so just suck it up
you think we want to be here 30 000 feet
in the air
[Music]
crazy crazy crazy